перше побачення як куля прошиває голову
оці міски на підлозі
Ну немає кому вийти на сцену і і Вибачте
мене
послати зі сцени
чи чи виступили ви в Кремлі Колись я
кажу і задоволенням виступив якби от з
батальйоном ми зайшли на цю площу там да
підняли український прапор стіни горять
Я стою отак от такі пісні потрібні
про музику під час
війни за кордоном та відмову від
російської культури сьогодні говоримо з
українським музикантом лідером гурту
Антитіла військовим та волонтером
Тарасом тополем Тарасе Вітаю Привіт
нещодавно ви провели перший сольний
концерт в Україні з часу початку
повномасштабного вторгнення і ви в
соцмережах написали що це було ніби
заново вчишся ходити коли ви стали
свідком великої війни Коли ви вступили
до лав ЗСУ ви відчували що ви можете вже
не повернутись на велику сцену і взагалі
не співати Які у вас були тоді взагалі
Думки щодо вашого майбутнього І що
справдилося що ні в перший день точно не
відчувалось що
чогось от не думав я про те що ми можемо
там загинути завтра там і перестати
співати створювати пісні взагалі інші
думки були от Потім після першого
бойового зіткнення в нашому батальйоні
коли пішли перші
наші побратими наші ті
коли пішли перші поранення
тоді
Так роздуплило що да Ти можеш загинути
завтра зараз наступної секунди от як
ракета яка прилетіла от пам'ятаєте
біля Солом'янському районі ракета
прилетіла в будинок розвалила половину
будинку біля на проспекті Лобановського
здається Ну це ж до нас летіла ракета от
аеропорт Жуляни і ну якби це наш був
район я чітко пам'ятаю цей вибух от В
нас труснуло так добряче нашому підвалі
на війні коли приходить доброволець він
підписує контракт з державою про те що
він своє життя віддає державі доручає
скажімо дає в користування навіть при
такому усвідомленні намагалися все ж
таки тримати в голові
не випускати що ми в першу чергу артисти
і як Бог дасть то ще прийдеться
повернутися до до музики от власне він і
дав як зараз сиджу даю це інтерв'ю ви
все ж таки зберегли ось це внутрішнє
відчуття що ви в першу чергу артист Ми
прекрасно розуміли що наша цінність
окрім того що ми ну трохи
нарізаємо в
тактичній медицині наша цінність - Це
наша медійність
і певні там силу цієї медійності певні
зв'язки в суспільстві ми використовуємо
цю медійність для того щоб допомагати
батальйону і використовуємо статус
справжній статус якби не на
папері десь А де-факто на практиці
прожити і кров'ю статус бойових медиків
для того щоб розповсюджувати правду про
цю війну за кордоном для deutcheве для
BBC для інших які казати там робити
правильні акценти просувати український
наративи нагадувати
сіяти Українську Правду ці це зерно
поміж місків всіх тих людей які зараз
дивляться на смартфонах в
комп'ютерах
Ну коли ви прийшли як медійна особа в
на поле бою фактично так то що було для
вас найтяжчим чисто із фізичної з
моральної точки зору
відповідальність найтяжче от я про це
говорив із друзями з музикантами
що
Якби мені було важко балансувати між
ініціативою і відповідальністю тому що
так Ну типу на війні Ти мусиш бути
ініціативним і брати на себе
відповідальність от але коли в тебе
відповідальність за життя кого якогось
сина батька
брата
от зробити все правильно щоб не
помилитись щоб не не самодеятельность не
займатись там і десь не
якісь ситуації тривожні екстремальні
зробити все правильно от за це найбільше
переживав тому що помилка ну бойового
медика вона вартує життя людини от далі
там був
були поранені яким так само надавали
допомогу От якби це були перші
емоції від війни
[музика]
одна з ваших крайніх пісень фортеця
Бахмут ви коли писали ці рядки як вони
вам писалися бо я знаю ви її записали за
один день На чому базується
саме ця тональність і ваші емоції в цій
пісні пережити
Той досвід сублімований який Антитіла
пройшли протягом цієї війни і це монолог
тому мені здається він так
сприймається
бійцями солдатами тому що там чесно
чесні слова і щирі прямий такий пряме
звернення
яке резонує ця пісня Не присядься не
лише тим хто б робить Бахмут - це один
із символів це те що актуально зараз це
символ звитяги подвигу
дай Бог щоб цього не сталося але завтра
може бути інше місто
и бахмуд - Це той самий Маріуполь
це все точки
українського супротиву
і кожне таке місто
зупиняє ворога
змелює його
от тому
Бахмут але це пісня про всіх хто
напередодні про всіх хто не проти то
якість і не горять і все от так що ця
пісня Вона для всіх багато хто каже коли
слухає цю пісню що Знаєте у неї нема
такого
однотонально-журливого якогось контексту
точно гниття виття це українське
завивання туга і журба мене просто
вибішує Це типу ми іноді треба я згоден
типу йоан антитіл є пісні присвяти
такі як в книжках такі як птаха
от але це одна з красок війни а зараз не
не Витя потрібні стіни горять Я стою
отак от такі пісні потрібні
поплачемо потім наплачемося ще ви
постійно спілкуєтесь з побратимами і
постійно з ними на зв'язку щодо допомоги
про що вас просять Захисники проти
снаряди розбило
пункт базування роти згоріло все Ну і що
вони тоді просять тільки привезли їм там
екофлоу там тільки привезли якісь речі
потрібні все згоріло автомати Ну все в
піддній білизні встигли чудом просто
встигли
вибігти це от північ бахмутчини це от я
розповідаю конкретну історію одна з рот
наша доблесна четверта рота 130го
батальйону
от і от що їм треба далі все треба
і трони і
генератори один з напрямок нашого фонду
- це антидронові рушниці ми збираємо
кошти на на закупівлю антидронових
комплексів От і ну якби на рівні
Міністерства оборони Є зрушення я так
надіюся що
генеральний штаб уже затвердить потребу
і воно буде включено в план закупівель і
там кількість таких антидронових
комплексів буде вимірюватися тисячами
в нашому війську поки що це сотні
одиниць а
такі штуки потрібні по суті в кожну роту
Тому що це є дендрона в рушниця це є
пеленгатор це така річ яка допомагає
присаджувати або виводити з ладу не
ворожі дрони в тому числі і
маленькі дрони і середні брони не знаю
Що там казати про якісь серйозні там
безпілотні літальні апарати там та але
от те що здебільшого працює на передовій
зі сторони ворога а от ця рушниця вона
виводить його з ладу садить робить
сліпим і таке інше там є різні опції
різні варіанти такого потрібно багато
дуже багато І от ми зараз закупили 5
антидронових комплексів тому що один
комплекс коштує 30 тисяч євро
російська пропаганда і все вище
політичне керівництво Ну так точно спить
і бачить як Європа перестає нам
допомагати волонтери за кордоном
втомлені Ви часто буваєте зараз за
кордоном в творчих поїздках що ви бачите
там по настрою європейців ми поїхали в
Лондон
в нас була
аудієнція з послом Сполучених Штатів
Америки в нас був виступ в резиденції
прийняття в резиденції
посла Сполучених Штатів Америці в
Америки в
United Kingdom у нас був виступ на
трафальгарській площі
де зібралася
Ну там
може поминути тисячі людей тисячі
українців зібрались от які небайдужі
який вболівають за Україну і серед них
точно Там є волонтери і і активісти
різні Ну були так на тій площі і потім
далі той же самий концерт який наш
сольник відбувся там ті люди з якими Ми
спілкувались там і з якими у нас було
мітинг Greed після концерту це все люди
які абсолютно не втомилися як посол США
і взагалі весь американський стеблішмент
тобто люди які реально роблять політику
Вони точно не втомились Можливо десь в
Польщі в Німеччині і в Британії є певна
категорія людей там які
яким важливіше там не знаю ціни на хліб
чи тепло і таке інше І вони через через
війну в Україні страждають і їх це
пригріть можливо так Я впевнений що такі
люди є от чи вони становлять
більшість яка якби вирішує політику
України на щастя Мені здається не
становить а щодо зацікавленості
європейців в Україні в творчому
контексті у вас нещодавно була зустріч і
співпраця творча з Боно до цього Це був
Ед ширан вони самі ініціатори Чи ви
якось на них виходите ми були в повному
складі ми запропонували Давайте зробимо
телеміст ми зіграємо в нескореному Києві
на Майдані Незалежності ви будете в
Бірмінгемі покажемо що ми боремось що ми
якби сильні що Київ не впав От і таким
чином впевнені що ми б заробили більше
грошей для українських біженців з цього
концерту
а от все оце єдиний був наш
ініціатива бачили що там буде ширан І
власне зверталися до нього це відео
стало вірусним
організатори концерту відмовили Ед ширан
почав комунікацію з антитілами і потім
вже його команда запропонувала взяти
участь в пісні to Step написати лірику
до цієї пісні далі ж Ед ширан
дуетширано звернувся Боно і попросив мій
номер телефону номер телефону бону потім
зв'язався бонус зі мною з антитілами і
вони приїхали в Київ і Ми заспівали
разом з ними
в метро
stand by Ukraine пісню В нас вивели з
передової на
24 чи 25 серпня я не пам'ятаю
Ми приїхали по запрошенню адашира на
заспівати наживо пісню To Step в Польщі
в Варшаві на стадіоні народовому і от
Тиждень тому назад
Боно
завітали до нас на концерт ми Їх
запросили в Лондоні Ми думали Ну якщо
прийдуть
це буде круто Ми соромилися взагалі
навіть
натякати на виступ тому що це
це легенди
от В мене є ця переписка з бону Я пишу в
my God якщо ви можете виступити звичайно
звичайно давайте виступи вони так типу
без проблем все ми еч бере гітару
ми заспіваємо і ми спільно прийшли до
рішення
щоб вони заспівали пісню
і присвятили її всім українським мамам
які чекають своїх хлопців
з війни
поза сценою Про що ви говорите з такими
медійними особистостями як Бона як Ед
ширан говоримо про різне взятим ширином
взагалі широкий спектр темп був йому
дійсно болить стосовно України от він
дійсно вважає що це несправедлива війна
і що так не має бути от і він дійсно
щиро Він дуже переживав типу що
хлопці щоб не щоб ви не сприйняли що
типу це якісь хайпи я намагаюся на темі
війни це кажу
такий хайп де ти якби з твоїм рідним там
і і де хайп на війні
те що ти робиш Ти просто відриваєш
шматок мільярдної своєї аудиторії і
віддаєш його Україні для того щоб вони
нас чули тому що ти відкриваєш двері до
них для нас
Це ж так працює прямо чи опосередковано
люди які люблять слухають пісні вони
слідкують за артистом і вони йому
довіряють якщо артист каже оці хлопці
правильно
оце правильно вони в це вірять і так
само бонус яєч от але вони прийшли зі
своїм зі своїми людьми зі своєю
аудиторією щоб підтримати Україну І це
це дуже потужні кроки Я дуже це ціную і
особисто
Я би хотів щоб Антитіла колись
поспівпрацювали з крістофором
Це мій улюблений режисер хотілось би
звичайно щоб інколи зняв фільм про
українську війну Як ви особисто як
людина як суддя нас відбору сприймаєте
Євробачення в цьому контексті в якому ми
зараз це можливість яка грає на руку
Україні все-таки транслювати наші
меседжі Чи все ж таки це виключно
творчий конкурс не був виключно творчим
конкурсом це творчо
суспільно-політи
чний фестиваль конкурс шоу ентертеймент
ці всі дискусії з цього приводу як
тільки перша бомба прилетіла одразу все
стає на свої місця імена російських
артистів спортсменів претедентки на Міс
Всесвіт науковців досі майорить в
списках учасників різних творчих і не
тільки творчих івентів на міжнародному
рівні Чи підтримуєте ви змінити це до
тої межі аби зробити так званий
кенселінг російської культури от повний
кенсель Та я підтримую повний концерт
російської культури фонау Як то кажуть
що робити з аргументами тих хто вважає
що це занадто жорстко ті ж самі
організатори ось таких міжнародних подій
які допускають російських учасників І
зараз я б їх би садив би в кінотеатрі в
такому дал далбісураунд і показував би
ексгумацію в Бучі
в Ізюмі в інших містах
як я міряю культуру якби в сухому
залишку по носію культури
от носії цієї великої в лапках
російської культури зараз чинять геноцид
проти українського народу Тобто всі ті
хто в школах в
ермітажах там в больших театрах
і на дискотеках
виховувалися на цій культурі
це А це сотні тисяч
на полі бою
своїм брудним чоботом топчуть нашу землю
і знищують і гвалтують і катують і
мільйони які їх підтримують
десятки мільйонів
це все от
продуцент
російської культури що мені ще треба
доводити комусь я за те щоб був повний
канцелянк а далі після того як Україна
переможе лише після того як
почнуться виплачуватись репарації
сім'ям загиблих і державі в цілому
сім'ям поранених пораненим лише після
того як
на державному рівні в Росії буде
визнання
актогенециду
каяття
після того можна почати вивчати
російську культуру там з позиції
наукової от як резервацію там взяти і
трепанувати її там розбирати по
частинкам А як так сталося
що ця от Російська культура призвела до
такого жахіття чи були за останній рік
пропозиції участі в європейських
міжнародних івентах Де брали участь
росіяни до вас запрошували не було в нас
Ми по суті до до вересня абсолютно ні в
яких не те що івентах А навіть не думали
про це бо ми служили тому що ми були на
Харківщині в той момент ну як би ви
реагували Якби завтра вас запросили на
музичний фестиваль де будуть росіяни
Якби ми знали про це з самого початку
звичайно ми відмовились А якби вже
приїхали пригували відповідно до до
ситуації звичайно тому що так виходить
якщо український артист приїжджає і
відмовляється виступати з росіянином на
одному фестивалі то виходить що росіяни
ж вони
черті
наглопрутім по барабану от виходить що
українці самі собі кенселінг роблять Ну
немає кому вийти на сцену і і Вибачте
мене
послати їх нахуй зі сцени Я вважаю треба
в кожній ситуації дивитися типу Да типу
і все измерять
тому що наприклад я кажу там чи чи
виступили ви в Кремлі Колись я б кажу і
задоволенням виступив якби от з
батальйоном ми зайшли на цю площу там да
підняли український прапор
ото був би класний виступ або наприклад
якби оце ще до війни та у нас було
багато пропозицій приїхати в
Казанський Кремль в Кремлі концерти Там
нас запрошували Та ну зрозуміло що ми
відмовлялись от але так між собою
ну сміялися з того Прикинь типу от
приїхати Ну там дадада конечно Мы
приедем споём там гонорар там обсудить
всё От і потім вилізти на сцену там
увалити не знаю Завжди моя підняти
український прапор сказати Слава Україні
там да ну тролінг такий да оце Ну типу
оці всі артисти там українські які
казали що Ну ми Ми ж українці Ну там до
війни
широкомасштабні які виступали в Росії от
ми ж там несемо українську там культуру
правда російською мовою там ну
менше з тим от я до таких артистів би
звертався що От якби ви дійсно от несли
українські то ви правильно би от робили
такі диверсії це ж Це ж реально
культурна диверсія була от вийти так
десь та і і
протулити на якомусь наприклад
державному заході на Кремлі чи на площі
прямо от український прапор герб
заспівати гімн от поки тебе не ОМОН не
зв'яже там в тебе є вікно можливостей Та
ну це б круто було Ну у нас бачиш
Антитіла не наважились на таке От
наприклад я думаю що Ваня Дорн міг би
таке зробити Угу Ну самі українці певним
чином досі толерують російську культуру
слухають російську музику прибутки з
якої теж ідуть в бюджет російської
Федерації а потім знаємо куди якби ви
могли якось на це Вплинути Що б ви
зробили
я б
реалізував би український Ферб були
якісь
де це в Китаї зроблено Ну так хоча б
років не 5 нам треба такий феєр-волом
треба поставити блок на все російське
детокс детокс зробити Тобто мають на
увазі інтернет
фільтрування російського контенту
інтернет
стрімінгові сервіси все-все просто
вичистити от Хай в місце це займає по
польській німецькій британський
український
місто це це ломка буде ну буквально
півроку
Ти теж саме в Тік током
це треба робити ланцюг ніхто не зробить
тому що це вдарить по рейтингу
тих хто буде це робити не знаю Якийсь
Міністерство яке буде це реалізовувати
чи чи хто От і це має ініціювати
насправді Міністерство культури
от спільно мабуть з СБУ з
тими органами які відповідають за
національну безпеку
ну мін цифри мають допомагати
Як би ви очевидець війни учасник оборони
України культурний діяч чи цю добу
розповідали про нинішнє покоління росіян
наприклад своїм онукам в мене наприклад
в телефоні
Гб відео різного
яке
Ми зняли протягом роботи наперед тому
мені здається що найперше якщо вони
будуть готові сприйняти це подивитися я
буду показувати Що росіяни робили з
українцями
от а далі нехай висновки роблять росіяни
мають бути принижені
Тобто це покоління воно має бути
принижене
нами українцями Всім цивілізованим
світом
і
з точки приниження
Вони мають шанс
якби
на виправлення наша
історична місія в українців
це
[музика]
декла декласувати їх як
певну силу яка може в майбутньому
становити загрозу для нашої країни для
Європи знищивши їх де-факто фізично їхні
броньовані машини їхні людські ресурси
і таке інше і ще принизити їх у всіх
аспектах так боляче буде
для
росіян але вони мають через це пройти це
як акт ініціації не знаю чищення от це
те що я впевнений чекає на на Росія
найближчим часом і вже Вони вже через це
проходять